is margarubby precious Margo are you  British I am not I am Australian ding  ding ding is margarubby  Harley Quinn who's that I am not Harley  Quinn but I play Harley Quinn oh right  that's your advice is Margot Robbie in  Transformers  random do I look like someone in  Transformers maybe maybe they just want  you to be in transformed maybe maybe you  should be a Transformer oh I could have  played that is Margot Robbie alive oh my  gosh  I'm not a tattoo artist I'm a person who  owns a tattoo gun and does tattoos but  there is no Artistry involved what's  been your worst tattoo uh the one I  spelled in correctly it was on suicide  squad we were doing Squad tattoos on  each other we're spelling skwad and I I